so where should and could Europe's IT
sector go let's ask someone who should
know your arcane buhler joins us now is
from bit calm the German Association for
information technology
telecommunications and new media it's
good to have you with us tell us why is
Europe lagging behind where are the
great thinkers and creative minds well
first of all I think we have a strong
ICT industry in Europe for all but still
the big company is the big player in the
web 1.0 but 2.0 are still in the US
that's true and I think we easy for it
right yeah there's a reason for it there
is some political reasons for it we
didn't well didn't actually see the
chances about digital age and we were
looking on our automotive we are looking
at our industries here in Europe but we
I think we we didn't take it serious
that the digital age is now coming and
there's a strong economic impact for it
but Europe once was quite cutting edge I
remember the 90s nokia european a phone
camping mobile phone company was let's
say like Apple is now and then it just
fell rapidly something went wrong in
Europe yeah well it's all about internet
I think well Nokia's like it's a company
which produces cell phones but it was
not connected real with the internet and
I think the internet web 2.0 is the
thing that we miss here here in Europe
and we should now see that we get into
next stage we were talking about the
industrial Internet in the u.s. that
means that two to bring the internet
together with our industrial economic
here in Europe and this is a very good
very big chance for Europe and we have
to keep on to get this into the digital
age but when you talk about the
industrial internet it also reminds me
of this is industry 40 we're sort of
touched on this briefly in our report
and are considering that Germany for
once has a very strong manufacturing
engineering sector shouldn't we have a
good chance catching up there or maybe
even taking the lead yes we can take the
lead we have a very strong industry here
in in Germany especially well twenty
five percent of our economic welfare is
made by industry and this is very big
chance and this is compared to other
countries like in like the u.s. a very
big advantage so this is our chance to
keep up in our products to make them go
into into the internet and this is a
very big chance for Europe okay you keep
saying a lot about this is our chance
but that alone will not be enough what
exactly needs to be done you think well
we need first of all the modernization
of our infrastructure is here in Germany
and in Europe as well the second thing
is that we need to tell communication we
need a very fast internet access the
third thing is we have to invest in data
security and data protection we need
laws from the European Union and we need
a new security culture in Europe and
then we have to to get special employers
and because it's one of the biggest miss
advantages here in Europe we need
employers we need specialist for the IT
and this is a very big problem and
there's politics has to do something
there's homework to do for us a lot of
political responsibility I can hear
their last question where do you see
Europe's IT sector our ICT sector in the
next 10 years well I hope that will be
the leading ICT sector for industrial
4.0 or the industrial Internet and that
the workers will imply be in Europe have
a strong economy a strong digital
economy ok Johan beulah thank you very
much for joining us you're welcome